verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
ist heute auf truppenbesuch beim
jägerbataillon 33 in zwölfaxing um sich
bei den verlängerten grundwehrdienern zu
bedanken
dafür möchte ich ihnen allen namens der
österreicherinnen und österreicher danke
sagen
bei ihnen allen aber auch bei allen
soldaten das einrücken
diese erstmalige verlängerung von
grundwehrdienern wurde von vielen
betroffenen mit gemischten gefühlen
aufgenommen wahrscheinlich so und so
sicher nicht mit 100-prozentiger mit
hundertprozentigem anspruch war mit
denjenigen mit denen ich sprechen konnte
die waren sich durchaus bewusst dass sie
in einer ganz besonderen zeit für die
sicherheit der österreicherinnen und
österreicher im beisein einsätzen in
zusammenhang insbesondere mit dem karola
wille da sein und dabei sein durften auf
jeden fall also da kam es zu einigen
diskussionen aber durch unsere
vorgesetzten wurden wir dann doch gut
belehrt und uns wurde klar gemacht warum
es ebenso wichtig ist dass wir eben
schauen dass alles ein recht und ordnung
bestehen bleibt und es wurde mit sehr
viel verständnis aufgenommen
wir sind uns aber schon bewusst dass das
eine historische maßnahme war die die
lebensplanung der jungen männer über den
haufen geworfen hat und daher ist es
auch nur richtig dass wir danke sagen
nicht zuletzt eben mit einer
anerkennungsprämie und jetzt auch mit
einem mit einem leibchen mit einem
sportlich war dabei stellvertretend für
alle verlängerten grund wird in der
werden symbolisch die t shirts
überreicht
ihnen stehen gedreht werden dankeschön
auch wenn es die meisten verlängerten
grundwehrdiener nicht mehr erwarten
können in das zivile leben
zurückzukehren
so mancher kann sich auch eine karriere
beim bundesheer vorstellen ja ich bleibe
sogar wirklich beim bundesheer ich
möchte gerne offizier werden
das habe ich auch nur dadurch entdeckt
dass ich eben beim grundwehrdienst mit
dabei war ein anderen gibt die
verteidigungsministerin nur beste
wünsche mit auf den weg
ich möchte die gelegenheit nutzen um
ihnen eine seines gute zu wünschen wenn
sie in das zivile leben in die zivile
welt zurückkehren bleiben sie vor allem
alle gesund